explosions and fires in crimea have
destroyed military equipment
frightened beachgoers
and prompted thousands of residents to
evacuate to russia
after more than eight years under
moscow's control scenes of war have
returned to crimea
for several recent incidents ukraine
hasn't claimed responsibility but
russia's operations have been seriously
disrupted as ukraine increasingly
focuses on striking facilities and
supplies behind russian lines actually
what they're doing is part of a broader
strategy which is to to try to squeeze
the russians out of the south of the
country so as the war enters a new phase
and president zielenski vows to take
back the territory at the heart of
russia's operations
here's why crimea has emerged as an
important battleground
[Music]
russia's military ceased crimea which is
internationally recognized as ukrainian
territory in 2014 since then moscow has
built military bases and weapons stores
on the peninsula
when russia invaded ukraine in late
february those hubs became important
locations from where moscow could deploy
forces and top up supplies
in the early days of the war crimea was
used as a jump off point for russia's
military russia's initial strategy was a
multi-directional invasion with the goal
of capturing keeve but after that failed
fighting shifted to eastern and southern
ukraine since then it's crimea has been
kind of a rare base
for russian armed forces
who are occupying the south of ukraine
ukraine is now
attempting to push those forces out
since taking control of parts of eastern
ukraine in july russia's forces have
appeared to slow down and ukraine has
repeatedly hit occupied areas with
targeted strikes on key infrastructure
that was being used by the invaders
ukraine it thinks it can't take the
russian all russians on in a tank battle
so they're being clever about it their
aim is to degrade the russians the the
ukrainian officials said said to me it's
like a thousand stings from a b
um in order to to disable um russian
capabilities their ability to wage war
and demoralize them and force them to
withdraw
crimea is now key to that strategy a
blast at a russian airbase on august 9
destroyed several warplanes according to
western intelligence officials and as
seen in these satellite images that
contradicted moscow's claim that no
warplanes were lost
russia blamed an ammunition explosion
and ukraine didn't take responsibility
for the damage
but the blast had consequences russia
relocated some planes and aircraft to
its mainland according to ukrainian
military intelligence
a week after the air base was hit
explosions at an ammunition depot
damaged rail tracks and power lines
complicating russia's efforts to
transport ammunition and other supplies
ukrainian officials said the attack was
indeed ukrainian and russian officials
blamed sabaters in their first official
acknowledgement of a major attack on the
peninsula
still that doesn't necessarily mean
ukraine is about to retake crimea
certainly crimea eventually is a target
but the ukrainians are going about it
very methodically
piece by piece
russian diplomats didn't respond to a
request for comment about the effects of
what's happening in crimea on moscow's
campaign but as a new phase starts in
the conflict the peninsula is at the
center of ukraine's efforts to show that
it can damage russia's army where it
didn't expect it